or in a part of town you used to live in
as a teenager you walk past the house of
a girlfriend you knew when you were 16
you look up to what used to be her
bedroom window from the outside
everything still looks the same though
somebody else lives there now
her parents are retired she's married
with two small kids in another city you
feel a searing nostalgia so everything
that was and no longer is it's not so
much her you miss more what you had who
you both were how things looked then
it's hard to explain what the feeling is
so it's confounding in its intensity at
that moment your phone rings it's a
friend who asks how you are you're at a
loss you don't quite know how to convey
your emotions and after a few attempts
just move on to other subjects unless
that is you speak Portuguese because if
you do there will be no need to struggle
you'll have the ideal word immediately
to hand you will simply tell your friend
that you're experiencing sad Dasha and
they will understand the word which has
no direct translation in any other
language means a bittersweet melancholic
yearning for something beautiful that's
now gone a love affair a childhood home
a friendship it's a blend of pain loss
and pleasure that loveliness once graced
our lives the underlying issue the
relationship between language and
feeling has long created debate in
philosophy some thinkers have proposed
that feelings are independent of words
babies for example can feel things long
before they know how to pin words to
their sensations but other philosophers
have insisted that certain feelings
would remain essentially unknown to us
if we didn't have the words to help us
recognize them the truth as so often lie
somewhere in an intriguing middle zone
language may not wholly create feelings
but it was definitely and beautifully
deepens and clarifies them the right
word helped us to know ourselves through
their agency we can more accurately and
securely identify the contents of our
inner lives the phenomenon becomes
particularly apparent
whenever we come across words in other
languages zero in on a feeling that our
own language doesn't have a succinctly
we notice then just how much a good word
can do to bring an emotion into focus
take for example the Turkish word
cruising which refers to the gloomy
feeling that things are in decline and
that the situation often political in
nature will probably only get worse
typically because of the Foley and
grandiosity of corrupt political leaders
how useful to have such a word to
indicate and commune with the depths of
grief unfolding in a Turkish soul or
more cheerily up in Norway they have
Pharrell's get a word that captures the
euphoric feeling at the beginning of
love when we can't believe someone so
perfect could have wandered into our
lives and has the goodness to think well
of us we might report I was overpowered
by far-off debt as our fingers in laced
but it isn't just a few magical words
and foreign languages that clarify our
minds this is what all great literature
may do what we call a good poem or novel
is ultimately one that reduces the
extent of our own self alienation and
misunderstanding and returns us to
ourselves after a lifetime of reading we
might know how to pin words and
sentences to pretty much everything we
feel however ephemeral and fragile it
might be it was this gift that
Shakespeare praised in a Midsummer
Night's Dream when he wrote that the
poet's I in Fine Frenzy rolling doth
glance from heaven to earth from earth
to heaven and as imagination bodies
forth the forms of things unknown the
poet's pen turns them to shapes and
gives to Airy nothing a local habitation
and a name
thanks to literature we can be rescued
from the closed diving bells we are
otherwise locked into the right words
break our isolation they are the agents
of and conduits to love
you